namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto sambha sambhu tassa namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto sambha sambhu tassa namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto sambha sambhu tassa
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
There are a couple of questions here, but they take me slightly off what I was hoping to address.
This morning, I'll come back to them.
This morning we talked about this business of creating our own suffering and all that.
And I just wanted to go into that just a bit more deeply.
The Buddha uses the word which translates as the world, loke.
He says in this world there is this dukkha and the end of it.
So dukkha is one of these very difficult words to translate because it has ideas which just doesn't make sense to us in terms of the word suffering
unsatisfactoriness gets close to it but it's really the whole gamut of human misery which all of us I'm sure have experienced so it's not only the sort of existential despairs and deep depressions and all that and death it's also the suffering that comes from our indulgence with pleasure the consequences of that the addiction and the grief when you lose somebody lose something
The attachment, the pain, that comes from attachment, which is always hidden, remember, because while you're actually enjoying something, it's heaven, not a problem.
When I say enjoying here, you've got to be careful, because we can get into the mistake that, therefore, we're not supposed to enjoy life, we're not supposed to enjoy smoked cheese, which is ridiculous.
It's trying to make a distinction between enjoyment and indulgence, which is very difficult for us, because
They're symbiotic.
They arise together very closely.
Aversion is easy to get because aversion immediately distances the object.
It makes it an enemy.
You want to push it away.
So one is not aware of any feelings of aversion, fear, all that sort of stuff.
When it comes to indulgence, it's a close marriage.
They're very difficult to distinguish.
Even so, distinguish we must.
So this word dukkha is
very wide ranging very wide ranging indeed and we're not completely free of it until we are liberated so that's the word enlightenment refers to the understanding to that clarity but liberation refers to the liberation from suffering now the way the Buddha uses the word world is
referring to the five khandhas.
Now these five khandhas are just a way of looking at the psycho-physical organism from the point of view of somebody who wants to become liberated.
So we have various models of a human being and it depends what you're actually looking for.
So if you're a Freudian then you'd think about your superego and all that sort of stuff.
But from the Buddha's point of view it was trying to
see the human being in terms of these five categories we call them heaps aggregates because they're all made up of bits so the first one of course is all to do with the body itself what we experience as sensation and it really is actually only talking about the body that we can sense not the body in itself because the body in itself we know very little of don't we I mean
have you any idea for instance you know what your liver's doing now when you have your biscuits there when you had your biscuits were you directing the amount of enzymes that were going into your stomach to digest it so there's a whole when you look into your body and actually ask yourself you know is this me you find out you don't know much about it directly we know from science you can read about it but in terms of our direct personal experience there's very little
a little that we're actually directly in charge of.
Self-die, multiply, I don't know what they do.
I'm the clue.
I breathe, but it's normally automatic, and something else takes care of this oxygen, carbon dioxide stuff.
I wouldn't know it was there, frankly.
I'm not that I've been told.
So, when the Buddha spoke about the body, although that's included,
it's really, really, he's talking about the sentient body, in other words, the body that we can sense through the five senses so it's mainly feeling, mainly feeling there's also sight and hearing direct contact, you see at the very base, remember, right here at the ear drum, all there is, is pressure there's no sound as such so all that's partitioned off, one side, you see
Then there's the next bit which is to do with perceptions.
So I'll put them together, perception and feeling, because in Buddhist psychology it always rides together.
As soon as you have a feeling, the mind, as it were, copies it.
And you have a percept.
It has some sort of mental image to go with it.
And as these images build up, so you move into more of a conceptual mind.
It can be concrete concepts, like Apple.
That can be anything, can't it?
or more abstract, but it all begins with these little percepts and feelings, he splits into those feelings that come into the body through those feelings that come through the body and those feelings that come from the mind in the body, from the heart in the body they include a whole feeling that we have within the body and the thing about Vedana, that's the word he uses
as opposed to the earlier feelings of the body, is that we distinguish them as pleasant or unpleasant.
Up until then, sensations are just neutral, but as soon as we perceive them as pleasant or unpleasant, even neutral, then we move into that area of feeling, feeling perception.
Now the next bit he calls sankāra.
which are those things that we compound, we make up by ourselves and the core ingredient of this is will so now it separates all this to point out that it's at this point that the creation comes in and the will that's creating these Sankara, these habits emotional, mental habits that's our inner atmosphere whatever you're feeling now in your general inner atmosphere whether it's peaceful or un-peaceful whether it's beautiful or un-beautiful
that's been created by acts of will.
And what we are experiencing is the conditioning of it.
So the mind is always producing this mental stuff.
And the final one is consciousness.
Consciousness here, not to be confused with this pure intelligence of Paññā, the Buddha within.
We're closer to it when we think of it as like a screen upon which things are thrown.
So it's like a television screen.
You've got all this input coming in and it throws it onto a composite picture.
And that basic knowing is what the Buddha is referring to as consciousness.
Now he says that this is the world.
But when he's talking about the world, he's not talking about something objective.
He's not talking about something out there.
And one of our Western fallacies is to presume that we can know the world as an object.
Something quite objectively outside ourselves.
So that when we look at a tree, we actually believe that the tree really looks like that.
Even if I weren't looking at it.
That would be true, wouldn't it?
One presumes that the tree you're looking at and you see is what everybody else is seeing.
and when you taste a bit of cheese you presume well this is how the cheese really tastes completely independent of my tongue's ability to taste this is how the cheese tastes and that fallacy really came up with our you know scientific revolution and of course it brought about huge science and technological advantage but it's left us in a bit of a delusion in the sense that
we have this idea that the world and consciousness are two different things that's where the delusion lies so the world as we know it, the world as we experience it can only be experienced by us it can't be experienced by anybody else and that's the world we are actually living in so just a simple for instance of this room so it's not as though
Buddhism would deny the existence of this room if we all left and disappeared it would still be here in some way but our experience of the room as we come in is individual to us so for some it might be a very pleasant room for others I remember when I was at the Vihara once and somebody came to see me who was a very strong Christian and when he walked when I took him into the shrine room you definitely get the feeling that he was walking into the devil's den and there was this sort of
shock, horror, and there's a moment there of resistance.
But he did give in.
So people have different ideas of how a room feels.
They have a different experience of a feeling of a room.
When you walk in, what did you see?
See, some people are very perceptive immediately.
They see the pictures, they see that, but other people don't.
They walk in the room and they walk out, they can't tell you what the hell was in it.
But they've been there.
I can't tell you what the wallpaper was or anything.
It's just the way they are.
They're not particularly interested, we could say.
So even though there are, I think, 11 of us in this room, there isn't a single room in terms of our personal experience, our personal experience of this room.
In other words, as the room exists for us, as the room exists for us,
So if we take that proposition, if we realize that the world I'm living in is actually being manufactured by me, dependent on, of course, the stimuli coming in.
For instance, a sound, I might hear some dogs barking.
The actual sound that's hitting my ears is always dependent upon my eardrum.
So obviously if I haven't got very good hearing, I'm not going to hear the same barks as you.
but the barks that come to me right will be the ones that I personally hear and at that perceptual level it's all very neutral I can look at something I can look at a bird and at the point of perception it's just neutral it's just a picture in my mind which I then project onto that bird you've seen that have you on these science programs how we
how when they study the eye looking over a picture, it's darting all over the place.
We're completely ignorant of that.
And all the time it's picking up these little pixels and throwing it back into the brain, the brain-mind complex.
And then the mind picks up an image, it finds the image, and it very cleverly projects it back on the picture.
It's quite amazing.
So we're not looking at the picture at all, we're just looking at what we're making out of the picture from all these little pixels coming through the eyes.
So it's the same with hearing.
All we're getting is little pressure points, and then the mind, the brain-mind has to take it in and make something of it, and then very cleverly projects it back onto the bird.
So we actually believe that we're hearing the bird.
But what we're hearing is what we have made up from these little sounds.
It was once when I was in meditation, I started getting this tinnitus.
And I would sit, you see, and my mind wouldn't be quite so, shall we say, steady and whatnot, and suddenly there'd be this tune, lovely little tunes going on, very creative, wonderful.
And then when my attention went to the actual tinnitus, it became a drone again.
It's all really weird.
And I kept playing around with this.
One minute it was just a plain, dead sort of drone, and the next minute it was playing these amazing Mozartian tunes
which I've failed to write down, of course.
So, when we begin to recognize that the world we're living in is the one we're creating, then the question has to come, how is it I'm not blissfully happy?
How is it that I've not found a way of creating a world which is full of peacefulness, joy,
So when the Buddha gets to his liberation, you see, or a more telling story really, somebody says to him, you know, this training to become liberated is very difficult, very hard.
And the Buddha says, yeah, yeah, of course it is, but when you get there, you get to Nibbana.
And the questioner says, Nibbana, so what?
He says, well, when you get there, you are, and his words are, contented and with it happily.
contented and with it happy so the contentment is the manifestation of no wrong desire to be content is to be at one with what there is even if it's not particularly brilliant and happy is the general state of mind now this happiness can be translated into all sorts of facets all sorts of modes
So it might be love, it might be joy, it might be just peacefulness, but the point is that it's happy.
So that's the proposition.
The proposition is the world we live in is actually being created by us and something is going wrong in that creation which is not making it contented and with it happy.
And the Buddha is saying that that's a possibility.
That's a possibility.
And his whole teaching is to try and get people to move from that position of being uncontented and unhappy to being contented and happy.
And in the five khandhas, in the five heaps that we've just described, that's like a slice in time.
if you were to just stop a human being and slice down right down there at that moment in time you get this congregation this aggregation of things but when it's in process then it becomes dependence origination the whole process of dependence origination and the point of interest for us is that point where the five khandhas these five groups have actually
got to a point of producing a contact with the world.
That's the moment.
This world, remember, is both the outside world, something we hear and see, but also the inner world of things that we feel, emotional states, thoughts, images, all that is our inner world.
All of them are objects to this consciousness.
So there's a sense base, there's the object, and there's the knowing of.
Then at the next point, there's a sort of basic duality in the world that we experience it as either likable or unlikable.
That's a given.
Even the Buddha had a bad back and didn't like it.
I'm sure he didn't like it.
I mean, he was given food, I'm sure, that he didn't particularly like.
But that's a given.
I mean, the food that he ate that was supposed to poison him,
he knew it was bad, one wonders why he took it, but anyway, he knew it wasn't so good, and he told Chunda, the person who offered him, he won't bury the rest of it, to leave a question mark in his mind.
So, that point of feeling, Vedana, the world splits into this likeable and unlikable, but you can still remain at peace with it,
That's the basic contentment.
But then something happens, remember, psychologically, which produces a relationship to this.
And that's what we call this wrong desire.
It's often translated as sensual desire, which I think narrows it too much.
It's just a wrong desire.
We don't have, remember, a good word to translate this tanha with.
Tanha is the desire arising out of wrong understanding, attachment and all that.
at that point, you see, there's a habit of just trying to grasp the object trying to hold it, trying to develop it and there's that desire there see, nothing's happened at that point that's why it manifests as an intention it manifests as a desire, as an intention and I was saying that if we can just remain at that point
to hold that point, to hover within that point, and recognize that movement, that desire, as being unwholesome, and just wait for the energy of that to dissipate, to just blow itself out, we're destroying that conditioning.
Okay?
We're destroying that conditioning.
And if it's, of course, a wholesome thing, then, of course, you empower it, you do it.
And just that very simple way, you just change yourself completely.
Okay?
all that negativity that we have begins to blow out, and all the positive stuff within us begins to grow.
Very simple.
Now, at that point, when that intention arises, nothing's happened.
It still remains at the level of potential.
That's the important thing to grasp.
So, if we have a desire arise, which we see is positively evil and terrible, and how could you?
See?
Then...
you don't get into, and guilt arises, or this huge thing about, I must be a terrible person.
Then you also note that as a judgment, because nothing's happened yet.
Now, you might have murdered somebody in the past, but that's irrelevant now.
At this present moment, the desire, the desire to do something evil may arise.
And if you just stay with it, you see, nothing's happened.
It still remains as just a potential, an idea.
And that's really, really important, because
If we start getting guilty, you're sitting here in meditation and suddenly you're throttling somebody, you see, and you start getting guilty about that, getting guilty, then you're going to create all sorts of psychological problems.
Actually, that's not quite right, because if you're already imagining throttling them, you've already potentiated that initial desire.
And although it remains only in the mind,
of course everything begins there there's nothing in the human world that the human creative didn't start in the mind whether it's the atom bomb or whether it's jet planes it all began in somebody's head somewhere so that initial desire arises now the next step remember is the grasping of it and that's the point where we identify where the want becomes I want see
Now, something happens there.
Something psychological happens.
You lose control.
That's the real bad thing.
You lose control because now there is anger.
Now I am angry.
There is a feeling of depression.
I am depressed.
At that point, you've sold your soul to the devil.
You can't get out of that anymore.
You've identified with it.
Of course, you can jump out quick and say, oh, don't stop, you know, no, there, there's depression, not me, not mine, you see.
But for that moment, you've lost, you've lost it, you see.
And that identity now is very difficult to stop.
Sometimes you can, you have to be really, really, really awake to stop the next step, which is to empower the desire, see.
And so that energy comes in and that's what the Buddha calls chaitanya, will.
Now, it's only at the point of identity that the suffering begins.
That's what we've got to really grasp.
When you're there and there's a desire, when you walk into, say, your kitchen at home and there's a desire for that biscuit, you see, if you remain there and just sort of hover over it and wait for it to pass, see, there's no suffering.
But as soon as I want the biscuit and there are no biscuits in the tin, then there's suffering.
See?
So, that point of suffering, the actual suffering doesn't begin until the identity.
So long as we're saying to ourselves, there is anxiety, there's depression, there's grief, there's all this awful stuff, there, it's not pleasant, nobody says it's pleasant, but it's not the same as I am.
See?
As soon as the I am comes in,
that's what the Buddha means by dukkha that's the dukkha of the dukkha that's the suffering of suffering and as I say at that point it's very difficult not to reinforce not to put energy into that original desire and that energy is the will and the Buddha says will is kamma that's your act if it's not been an act and therefore there's no actual consequence until something is empowered
and as soon as it's empowered the I is reproducing itself and that's why he uses the word bhava becoming I'm constantly becoming this I see so every time like for instance somebody's you know played a little trick on you played a little trick on you and you know you've seen the irritation come up and
and you've been very mindful, it's there, it's very strong in you, this irritation, but you don't join in.
And then there's just a little slippage, and before you know it, you've manufactured this little daydream of telling this person exactly what you think of them.
Now, at that point, you see, there was, first of all, the desire, you see, the irritation coming up.
Then there's a moment where there's a loss of mindfulness, and that means there's a becoming of the irritations.
As soon as you become the irritation, it slips up into this wonderful intellect we have, this imaginative intellect, and produces something.
Now, in our meditation, what that's pointing to is to be very much aware of what the mind's thinking about all the time.
Because unwittingly, it's developing these conditionings.
That's why in our meditation we're always taught very quickly, as soon as you come out of a fantasy, whatever it is, you note what the attitude is.
Not concerned at all with the subject matter.
That's irrelevant.
It's just this emotional state, this conditioning, grasping hold of something in the memory and making something of it to develop that mental state.
So if I'm angry, if there is anger in me, the desire is to develop the anger.
It might be righteous anger.
That's the best of them all, righteous anger.
You can blow the world apart with righteous anger.
And what you're doing is you're creating this imaginative world in which this anger is developing.
Now, that's the sequence, you see.
You have the contact.
A feeling perception arises, which you, in this case, in this negative sense, you perceive as unwholesome.
And then there's this reaction of wanting to do something with it, either to develop it or to get rid of it, if you don't like it.
Wanting, not wanting.
There's a sudden falling into an identity, I want, I don't want, and then I do, or I don't do.
There's your sequence.
And once that's done, once the doing is committed, whether in the mind, I'm just talking about the mind at the moment, that reinforces the whole of these conditionings, these sankhās.
now so long as it stays in the mind in a sense it's only doing us harm it's only creating an inner environment which is not very pleasant but it's very difficult once you've established a mental attitude not to begin to launch it out onto an unsuspecting world
So what was angry inside your own heart, your own mind, suddenly begins to manifest in the way you speak and in the way you talk, in the way you act rather.
So the outward flow of the mental states is very difficult to stop once you've actually begun it, once you've actually started developing this mental state.
So if we're clear about that, then
When we're sitting, that's our purpose, is to get down to the heart level of attitudes, the felt level of an attitude, and to stay with it and allow it to burn out.
And that demands, of course, a growth in patience, a forbearance, which is really difficult to be with.
If we suffer from anxiety, fear comes up.
Fear of fear, that's your panic, isn't it?
And just to be able to stay with that, you know, just to, not to move, you know, be like a mountain, just not to move and just wait for that, wait for that nausea and awful feelings just to pass away.
And of course the more you do it, the more you grow in patience and the more you grow in courage to turn into these inner demons.
And that constitutes the purifications.
So when the Buddha says that he's got rid of all desires, that's what he's talking about.
He's talking about exactly what we've been describing.
Got rid of all that negative desire stuff.
And remember just, you know, when we talk about this, although we always talk about, or generally speaking we talk about things,
that are quite negative within us like anxiety and anger and all that it's also remember all the indulgences we have all the lusts all the desires all the grieves which we experience as rather pleasant when the mind is dreaming away on it these things also become very obsessive the lust for power nothing like it so that's all how to deal with the Buddha is saying you know you've got to be at that level
where the Vedana, this mental state has arisen, and the reaction to it, the desire.
If we can stay with the desire to develop, to indulge, or the desire to reject long enough and let it just die away, we're actually allowing this original stuff to blow itself out.
That's all.
now to see that is to see this sequence of events of the desire and how the I comes in so even at this point we're also seeing the impermanence of these states but we're also seeing this business of the I this self that the Buddha keeps talking about this idea that the self is
the deeper root cause of our problems now if we go back to the beginning of that dependent origination he always starts with this word avijja which translates directly as not knowing sometimes you get translated as ignorance and that in a sense gives it a twist which is not there like you know you should know you're ignorant but it's not that it's just not knowing and because of this not knowing
we presume to be what we experience that's about it we presume to be what we experience so we experience ourselves as human beings and therefore we presume that's what we are conventionally speaking we know we're human beings but in any ultimate sense then it doesn't have any substantial meaning to it because
This me is constantly in a process of change, constantly changing its parameters, constantly changing its understandings, constantly changing its experiences.
But somehow, within the whole of this life experience, there seems to be this center point which never changes.
Have you noticed that?
This me always is there.
It doesn't matter what happens on the outside.
I can lose both arms and both legs and my nose, but me, I'm still there.
I can change all my opinions and do all sorts of things, but this me remains completely constant.
It never seems to move.
The sense of this deep inner sense of presence.
Correct?
See?
Now, the Buddha says this is the root.
This is the root cause of all our problems.
This very sense of self, this very feeling that we have of being me.
Now the fact that we are aware of it, the fact that we actually know it's there, tells us immediately we can't be that.
You can't be something that you know as an object.
Yeah?
Being, to be something, it's like, for instance, they say very well in the Mahayana,
the eye cannot see itself.
But it does perceive.
But it can't see itself.
If it could see itself, that would be really interesting, wouldn't it?
It can see itself by way of reflection.
We can see our faces in the mirror and we can fool ourselves to think that that's how people see us.
But we don't, do we?
They see our faces the other way around.
It always comes as a shock when you use two mirrors.
Because you never thought your nose was quite that twisted.
It's like your voice.
You hear it on voice.
It's only when you hear it coming out from a loudspeaker or something that you think, God, that sounds terrible.
We have this view of ourselves.
It's always very, normally speaking, fairly positive, I think.
And we think that that's how actually people experience it.
But they don't.
So the eye can't see itself, the tongue can't taste itself.
See, even here, within our experience of this body, we're being told that you can't be something you're aware of.
If the basic sense of your tongue was curry, how could you ever enjoy ice cream?
It'd be difficult.
Everything would be a lovely taste of curry.
So it's the fact that the tongue is empty of taste that it tastes.
It's the fact that the eye can't make images that it sees images.
So there's something within us which is beyond the phenomenal world and yet able to receive it.
That's the proposition.
When the Buddha talks about in that victory verse he uses this little phrase chittam asankhatam this word chitta you see
translates as a consciousness a knowing which is not conditioned not conditioned now everything in the phenomenal world is conditioned in the sense that it depends on something else yeah everything that everything you see in this world is leaning on something else is dependent on something else is in relationship with something else for it to be yeah
I mean, we take so much for granted, but we know that, you know, we have four minutes if we don't get air.
That's not very long, is it?
Four minutes.
Nine days without water.
I think it's two months or three months without food.
And we forget that dependency.
We forget, in fact, that this body is like a fountain.
There's stuff coming in and stuff coming out all the time.
It's a double-headed fountain there.
and in the process it sort of changes so there's something in us which is receiving all this material knows all this material feels all this material experiences all this material and yet is not of it so now this process that we go through in vipassana
right it's about turning the inner world into an objective world in the same way that the young child around about the age of four months or something begins to externalize the world that it experiences as totally me I think in psychology they call it the first object relation your mum usually yeah and that's the first out of this massive of sensation if you can
it's difficult for us to imagine, isn't it?
But it's just all sensation, and you can't make sense of it.
All you know is pleasant or unpleasant.
When it's unpleasant, you scream.
You know, the world's coming to an end.
And then, suddenly, this thing separates out.
Sometimes you see little children, you know, where they're trying to make a go at some rattle or something.
And what they're doing is, you know, that's what they tell you anyway, is they're building up this three-dimensional world.
before it's just presumably it's just flat and suddenly they see this thing and they're reaching out for it and they're creating distance they're creating this three-dimensional space and at some point or other they become quite aware that there's a world out there might not be conceptual I don't have words for it but there's something out there and there's something here quite separate and all we're doing is taking that process inward
That's all.
So whereas we have bathed ourselves, confused ourselves with all the inner world that we experience, our thoughts and imaginings, our feelings, our bodies and all that.
Soon as you sit in meditation and these become your objects, they become the other world.
You're dis-identifying with them.
And that little distance that you feel between the knowing and what is being known is
we can call it a Nibbanic gap don't quote me it's a Nibbanic gap because somehow we've pulled out and it can no longer affect us when we're sitting in meditation and perhaps we're dealing with a very pleasurable feeling a very joyous feeling comes up in the body
and it wants to attach itself to something.
So it begins to think about this planning, this business you're going to set up, which is going to conquer the world.
And you stop it doing that and you still stay with this sense of excitement, a slightly excited sense of joy.
And as you separate from it and it's there, it's got no power, it's lost its power.
It can't get into the mind, it can't begin to create.
It just remains as a lovely little feeling.
And then slowly it passes away.
If there's a grasping after it, if there's a wanting it to stay there, then we haven't distanced enough, we haven't let go of it.
It now becomes that connection which we might not have perceived while it was there, but as it fades away there's a desire to grasp at it.
That little connection, see that's the tanha, that's the beginning of suffering.
but if we're just there absolutely equanimous see like the Buddha's always got his left hand resting equanimous and it fades away and there's no reaction there's only an interest in that process of fading away then it's not touched us it's not it's not grasped us or rather we've not grasped it but that's how the feeling is that it's not taken as oh we're not being hijacked by it see so
All these things that come up in the meditation, pleasant or unpleasant, and neutral, we'll come to that in a minute, are all points where we can begin to experience this distance.
And every time we pull ourselves out from that relationship, we are unwittingly establishing a different relationship.
And that different relationship is taking us to a place, slowly but surely, which is completely in the world,
the Buddha didn't exit the world once he was liberated he didn't sort of just disappear or something and yet untouched by it unaffected by it in any negative way now as you we can get so far remember with our acts of will when pain comes for instance in the knee
So the normal thing is, the first sensation of it, you might just get that feeling of just not wanting it.
So there's your desire, right?
But it's not big enough yet to grasp you.
So you just stay with it, and you wait for that to pass.
If the pain gets really bad, then you get a deeper sense of aversion towards it, a fear that your knee's going to explode, all that sort of stuff.
And you're just watching it.
You never get involved.
You're just feeling it.
Your attention goes to the reaction.
Hmm?
As the reaction dies away you're left with just this pain.
Right?
You're equanimous with it.
Not that we try and defeat pain.
Yeah?
You never win on that one.
But so long as it remains manageable.
Yeah?
So you then go into the pain and you come across sensations which constitute the pain.
So that's at the level of the first aggregate we're talking about.
That's when you're experiencing pain not as pain but as tightness or heat or pressure.
Hmm?
And at that level you notice there's no desire.
It's a perfectly equanimous level to be at the level of contact.
As you move your attention or it slips back into a step before that and the perception pain comes up, you see, then you realize that there is no such thing as pain.
That's a mental person.
What there is, is sensation.
Now that doesn't mean to say that it's useless because
If we don't recognize pain, then we obviously can do ourselves damage.
But it's just knowing that pain is mental and not physical.
And as soon as that word pain comes up, you've got this reaction.
Just to observe that process, you see, is to observe how we create the world out of this, how we're creating that world around pain in just that little experience.
And you can do the same with an emotion.
Okay?
so when anger comes up and you feel irritated about something, you see you stop it from creating a world, right?
this imaginative world and you come back into the body and you may still feel it as anger but as you go into it it becomes just heat heat and fiery energy and then you know that that's what it actually is and it's the mind that then conceptualizes it
In this sense it's the other way around because the mind is full of this fiery stuff and it's affecting the body.
And in some of your meditation sometimes you can see that separation that the mind with feeling separates from the body with feeling.
And it's those sorts of little insights that make it very easy for us to understand how there are psychosomatic illnesses.
Because the mind itself
is making the physical part of our body sick it's confusing it so we pull out from the body with its sensei pull out from the heart with its emotions and when it comes to images we can also just note them but you have to be very careful because
in placing your attention on an image, it's often actually empowering it, and the image can take over.
So again, you just note the image, come back to the breath.
And there comes that point where there's just this knower, just this witness inside you, the feeler, the observer, the one who knows, the experiencer, call it what you wish,
And that's really the final point you can get to by an act of will in your meditation.
And if you're very still at that point, you know, occasionally it comes, turn your attention towards that, towards that feeling.
Where's that feeling, that sense of a self being manufactured?
Now, on the positive side, that's all this negative stuff, on the positive side, remember that that whole process is developing very positive attitudes in us.
It's developing that sense of discriminative inquiry.
It's developing patience and forbearance.
And also, remember, you can flavor your looking with kindness.
So you're looking kindly upon yourself, kindly upon these things.
Now, when it comes to
sorry and the other thing he's developing is this equanimity this complete openness to the way things actually are to see and understand the way things actually are that's the Buddhist phrase it's translated literally to see and understand the way things come to be because the Buddhist question remember is never why we're suffering but how he's not interested in metaphysics he's interested in this process of how we create suffering and in seeing it
He's presuming that we'll see how to end it.
So that's what the vipassana is about.
The vipassana is about seeing this process, to see it as impermanent, to see it as not me, not mine.
But when you then come out of your meditation, you see, there has to be a translation of that understanding into an attitude.
And that's where the metta comes in.
So whereas intellectually or understandingly we might begin to experience or understand this idea of interconnectedness, it remains very dry unless it's turned into an attitude of love, of a quality of love, whether it's sympathetic joy or compassion or any other quality that you can think of which you would put under that large umbrella of good relations.
And that's what the practice of metta does, right?
Now, in some traditions, and you have to agree, it's not absolutely necessary because the wisdom would translate naturally into an attitude.
But it does, I think, help to make that little effort to develop goodwill.
And then that's why every morning there's that point where I remind people to make an act of will for the day.
What is your resolution for the day?
It doesn't matter whether you keep it or not.
What matters is
that you keep, as the Buddha says, inclining to Nibbāna, just leaning in the right way.
So if you lean far enough, you tend to take a step.
So these little resolutions in the morning, which every time you lose it during the day, you reinforce it, they have this effect of making you do it.
There's a rather nice passage in Joseph Goldstein's work, which he wrote about his experience right at the beginning, about the experience of insight.
And if I remember rightly, he would get up very early in the morning to do this meditation and fall asleep.
But he didn't say, oh well, I'm just too tired, it's obviously not working for me, I'll just sleep a bit more.
No, he just kept getting up and going to sleep.
And then one morning, I think two or three months on, he got up and he didn't.
And that's it, that's how it works.
You keep empowering your good intention and you keep tripping over and forth.
You pick yourself up, you dust yourself off, you start all over again.
And then one day, you're doing it.
And it always begins, remember, in the mind, with intention.
So these little resolutions at the end of a sitting, it can be specific to something you're going to have to meet during the day.
It can be general.
And it can be either a negative one, that you're not going to go down that road.
I would always suggest that one.
And a positive one, that this is the path you're going to take.
You see?
And every time you know you've slipped, you reinforce your commitment to those resolutions.
And this immediately begins to have an effect on the way we speak.
You see?
That's right speech.
And then it affects how we just generally behave, right action.
Which is always on an ethical basis.
Because remember, the self, the self is always...
self-endearing it's self-protective it begins you see not from the point of view of evil but from the point of view of delusion and so it feels better if it's bigger and it considers bigger being richer and more powerful and and all that sort of stuff so the more you have in the bank the more happy you feel you might not i mean it's like um
Spike Milligan said, wasn't he?
He said, they say money doesn't make you happy, but I would just like to have a go.
I just want a chance to prove it.
So the self is always trying to substantiate its existence to make itself feel safe.
Remember, that's the fundamental fear of the self, that it is not safe.
That's why it can't handle sickness over age and death.
it doesn't make itself feel safe.
So everything you could say on a positive level when we're working from this particular delusion is just to make ourselves feel safer.
The fact that it's at the expense of everybody else in the world is irrelevant.
What is relevant is that I feel safer.
And so all action in terms of this process of liberation is always around some sort of ethical basis.
And then there's right livelihood.
Now, it's very interesting that the Buddha should put that there, because logically speaking, I suppose you didn't need it, it's included in right action, but he does.
And there's your livelihood, if you think about what the virtues, the traits of your personality, which your actual employment is developing.
So whatever we do for the better part of our lives, those eight or so hours a day, they're having an effect on us.
So somehow we have to make sure that whatever we're doing is done with right attitude.
So if you're doing a brilliant job, begrudgingly, what's the point in terms of this process of liberation?
If you're doing what seemingly might be to other people a menial job or something,
not an important job it is important to that person if they make the decision that this is what I'm going to develop in this work I mean the kernel experience in my life was when I was a kid and I went to work I got this holiday job in this factory making cakes
And it was one of these old belts that came around, these cakes.
And all the women were standing there.
And they put me on the end of the line of these women.
And for them, it was utterly automatic.
My job was to put the cherry on top of this thing as it passed by, you see.
And of course, for them, they were yapping and talking, having a whale of a time.
And they were just doing all this stuff just like that.
You see, when it comes to me, I'm starting to put this damn cherry on.
Every so often, I'd miss.
And the machine had to stop.
And the foreman would be shouting at me.
They were all very kind looking at this boy, you know.
Oh, leave him alone.
And of course, I remember thinking to myself, what a dreadful, what an awful job these poor women have got to come in and do this all day, you know, for eight hours making these cupcakes.
Looking back now, of course, from the point of view of the meditation, what an amazing opportunity to develop concentration.
Moment to moment, concentration on that cake.
As it passes by, cherry spot on in the middle.
Never missing.
Eight hours.
God, I'd have come out enlightened, I'm sure.
I'd have completely liberated from all cakes anyway.
So it doesn't matter what you do, you see, eventually.
It doesn't matter what you do.
It depends.
I mean, apart from the obvious unethical things that we can do, it's the attitude which you're doing.
It's your resolution as to what
your work is that develops in you and to do it for that reason and for doing it when we do something for virtue it automatically benefits the other you don't have to worry about whether it's benefiting the other or not they might not receive it so well but the point is it is to their benefit
And that's how the rest of the path right speech, right action, right livelihood begins to recoil back into the mind.
So where we started in the sitting posture getting that vantage point allowing negative states to arise and burn away beginning to develop that wisdom about who we are, what we are as it moves into daily life it actually is developing these mental states
so that our inner life becomes more and more joyful more and more more and more peaceful that's the theory I can only hope my words have been of some assistance may you by your deep and profound commitment to the practice
move towards your liberation sooner rather than later